it's got to you know select people who
are just not going to be massive
puddings like we have just had you know
completely non-impressive people as MPS
for a long time and that is very much
Katie said that is very very true of um
the Tory party I thought was interesting
this week William Hague wrote in the
times that actually we should think
about that dirty word the e word elitism
returning to politics a bit we should
actually strive to have really good
interesting people in Parliament who
will not just be good constituency MPS
and that you know you should be a good
constituents MP but you can also
actually you know serve on a national
stage or an international stage as well
because you look at the quality of MPS
in this party from from both sides labor
and Tori of the last couple of intakes
and you think yeah this is not a
Pantheon of greets but by a long stretch